Herkese
[Alkış]
merhaba Hayat kimimize göre uzun
kimimize göre kısa Bazılarına göre tam
olması gereken uzunlukta bir yol bu
yolda karşımıza yol ayrımları yol
arkadaşları tabela var kurallar kanunlar
bize Bazen çok cezbedici gelecek Işıklı
Yol kıvrımları çıkacak benim bu
yolculukta en çok önemsediğim En mühim
bulduğum şey memnuniyet kendi yolunu
sevmek ben kendi yolumu ve mutlak
memnuniyetimi kendi ellerimle
kazanıyorum bunun için çok mutluyum
birazcık Aslında hepimizin bu hayatı
Yaşarken bir Disiplin ve bir sistem
oluşturduğumuz u düşünüyorum ben
telefonu bırak kendi ekolünden
bahsedeceğim size
Ya aslında hepsinin temelinde yatan şey
ana kuram hislerinize yaşamak bence
insan bazen nerede olması gerektiğini ne
olması gerektiğini nasıl olabileceğini
bilmeyebilir hepimiz gibi ama
bu ne istediğini Ne yaparken mutlu
olduğunu her daim bileceksin Tabii bir
de bu şeyi yapmamız gerekiyor bir şeyi
yapmakta onunla ilgili çok pratik
yapmaktan geçiyor O yüzden bir şey Hey
iyi yapıyorsanız Ve bunu yaparken iyi
hissediyorsanız aslında kendi cennetini
dünyada bulmuş oluyorsunuz ve bunun
güzelleşmesi çiçeklenmesi mümkün
olmadığını düşünür biraz size kendi
hikayeden bahsedeyim Ben Anadolu
Üniversitesi mimarlık ve tasarım
Fakültesi moda tasarımı bölüme yerleştim
hep zaten estetik algısı yüksek bir
çocuktum büyürken be sevdiğim bir alandı
görsel sanatlar plastik sanatlar ilgi
alanım olduğu bir alandı zaten
Sonrasında da bu yaşamında da sürekli
var olan ve var edecek olduğu üretecek
olduğum bir alan haline geldi birçok
markayla işbirliği yaptım ya onları sil
içeriklerini üretim kendisi içeriklerini
üretim dijital platformlarda da kendi
üretimleri mi sağladım sonrasında Şeyma
Subaşı'nın stil danışmanlığını yürüttüm
bir süre onun istok iyi bir uygulaması
var ve orada içerik üretti ama sonra
beni
heyecanlandırma yan bir nokta olduğunu
düşündüm aynı Biraz önce anlattığım gibi
yani İyi daha iyi hissettiğim alanlar
vardı ama oğlanlar da çok erkek Egemen
alanlarda Mesela ben darbuka çalmayı
seviyordum ama darbuka çalan çok kadın
yoktu bu darbuka çalma durumu da ile
üniversitedeyken vurmalı çalgılar
topluluğu işte yeni öğrenciler arıyor
afişini gördüm ve halkbilimi
araştırmaları merkezine gittim orada
dünyanın birçok halkının kültürünün
müziğinin danslarının öğretildiği bir Bu
çok güzel bir durumla karşılaştım
sonrasında Asıl benim hayatımı
değiştirecek noktalardan biri
bu ve insan Selçuk yükseldi hocamla
tanıştım İyi çaldırma kanaat getirdi ve
bana bir kanal oldu bundan sonra Ben
nereye gidersem sen de benimle birlikte
Geleceksin dedi ve bize ki gibi kurumsal
büyük firmaları beraber çalıştırmaya
Gittik Tabii ki ben Canon sadece
kendisini sadece Asist ediyorduk ama çok
eğleniyordu ve öğrenciydim çok fazla
vaktim vardı çalmaya başladım ama her
şeyi çok merak ediyorum ve çok seviyorum
multidisipliner perküsyon seviyorum
Bongo Tüm bu Afrika enstrümanları
darbuka Tabii ki naçizane benim
yine dışına Cam nasıl müziği piyano ile
başlanırsa bitme perküsyonda darbuka ile
başlanır Çünkü kendisi biraz zor bence
tırmandı kötü çalana çok tahammül olmaz
ve
en çok huzur belli eder onu çaldıktan
sonra diğer Bus resimleri daha rahat
çalabilirsiniz daha güzel bir teknik
geliştirebilirsiniz O yüzden ben iyi
darbuka çalmaya başladım yani buna
yatırım yapmaya başladım ve gerçekten
sürekli çalıyorum sürekli Emek verdiğim
bir şey gelişiyor dönüşüyor Ama takdir
edersiniz ki
bu Star bu kocaman kadın yok ve aynı
zamanda darbukada Genelde arabesk
fantezi müzikler de kullanıyor ve ben
hiç böyle müzikler dinlememiştim bu
yaşıma kadar Neyse darbukayla kendi
dinlediğim müzikleri çalmaya başladım
Klasikler de çalmaya başladım
bana hitap eden metal Hatta Michael
Jackson da falan çalmaya başladım Daha
Biricik bir şey olmaya başladı ve
insanların dikkatini çekti yine
Türkiye'de çok fazla olmayan bir
enstrüman çalmaya başladım O da dikkat
çekmeye başladı ve yaptığım şeyler
hepözgün hem Biricik hem de istediğim
gibi oldu bu dünyadaki kendi cennetini
kurduğunu düşünüyorum bunları yaparken
okulda gönüllü olarak rossel Kampüs
sorumluluğunu yürüyordum Aslında gönüllü
bir çok projede yer alıyordum O yüzden
gönüllü çalışma kültürün oluşmuş
gönüllülük Sen bir arkadaşım bana bir
teklif bu burada Büyükşehir
Belediyesi'nin bir etkinliği olduğunu ve
orada bir dövüş ok bir ip veremeyeceğim
ile ilgili bir gittim Hocama izin
istedim bir icazet aldım Daha doğrusu
ben çok yapayım gibi düşünmüyordum ona
bahsettim O da beni yüreklendirdi
Sonra gidip kendi ilk defa ritim grubumu
oluşturdum ve çalmaya başladık
öğrencilerine enerjiniz çok tuttu onları
çok sevdim Ve gerçekten benim için
inanılmaz bir telli boldu sonrasında
gibi etkinliğe dair etler çocuk
tiyatroları Festivali ne o gün belediye
başkanımız geldi böyle beni sormuş
Kendisi bu kız kim falan diye tuttu beni
kadroya aldı ve ben Büyükşehir
Belediyesi'nin vurmalı çalgılar
topluluklarının şefi oldum Hayatımda
gördüğüm en küçük en önemsiz
şey çektim ama ben çok çalıştım
Gerçekten böyle bir sorumluluk aldıkta
sen kendini geliştirmek için daha da
çalıştım ve çok sevdiğim bir şey olduğu
için bu alanda Aslında çalışmak değil
sadece yaşamakta Benimki O yüzden zaten
şu an çalışmasam yine giyinip süslenirim
insanlara bu konuda yardımcı olmak
isterim Yine çalarım Kendi müziğini
yaparım o yüzden ben aslında hiç
çalışmıyorum bu yola girdiğimde bana hem
ya darbukanın vizyonunu değiştirdim daha
farklı bir şey gibi geliyor diyenler
oldu bazen de artık açılıyor Kız zaten
diyen insanlar oldum İkisi de beni mutlu
eden ne de üzen şeyler de gerçekten ben
sadece keyif aldığım şey defalarca
yapmaya devam ettim enstrumanı şekilde
en çok fazla bu ülkede olan bir şey
değildi neoya mangal gibi ya da hani
gözleme saçı hala bunu söyleyen çok
fazla insan var ona benziyor öyle bir
şeyler tamam bu gözlemeci kız falan gibi
bir yerler vardı bir de inanılmaz bir
şey yapıyor Bu kız çok başarılı
yetenekli bir dini insanlar vardı Her
zaman sizin için bir şeyler
söyleyecekler siz geliyorsunuz da
başarıyla iyi hissederek hislerinize
güvenerek ve kendinize güvenerek yürüyün
o zaman Atatürk'ün dediği gibi hiç
dinlenmemek üzere yola çıkanlar asla ve
asla yorulmazlar
her daim yolunuz gönlünüz açık olsun her
şey mucizevi bir şekilde hayatımıza
düşsün beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]